I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
being with us
we are American Presidents managed to
capture the spirit of the time in just a
few words
Reagan really did make us believe it was
finally after Jimmy Carter mourning in
America
after eight years of bush Obama
galvanized the electorate with hope and
change
but with Biden and his team the message
is the opposite of hopeful instead he
offers little hope and change most of us
don't want
there's a need for bold action to fight
this pandemic we're still facing a very
dark winter here's a situation
and when it comes to the gas crisis
we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place and God willing
when it's over will be stronger the idea
we're going to be able to you know click
switch bring down the cost of gasoline
is not likely in their term we aren't
likely to see the kind of Blockbuster
job reports month after month like we
had over this past year
but that's a good thing
yeah that's a good thing
and remember record high gas prices are
good too because it means that more of
you are going to be forced to take out a
loan to buy some electric car that you
can't afford and you don't want
the fact that Americans are getting
poorer under Biden's kind of European
style socialism is also a good thing as
far as the elites are concerned
let's face it they've always preferred
countries like France and Germany over
the United States and now they're happy
because they're steering us into that
direction
our customs our Traditions our history
our national memory they're being
attacked on a daily basis by high prices
Marxist Educators and left-wing
activists
but the good news is and there is good
news voters seem to be ready to deliver
an electoral Smackdown to the Democrats
anti-American Crusade a new Gallup
survey says that only 14 percent of U.S
adults say the economy is excellent or
good a staggering 46 percent say it's
poor and 39 percent say it's only fair
that's negative 32 on the confidence
index even worse 77 percent say the
economy is getting worse no improvement
at all from March and April
so what's the Democrats answer for this
what do they plan to deliver for the
overwhelming majority of Americans who
soured on the future we came critically
close
uh to lose in this democracy who was
calling who was texting who was emailing
uh doing those 187 minutes to see
whether or not uh that information will
let us know if people uh were part of
the problem we know that this crime
started at the very top When Donald
Trump propagated the big lie aimed a mob
at the Capitol and then had others lie
and cover up for him
yes that is all they have for the
American people January 6 white
supremacy a run on the Second Amendment
hints at court packing even
an endless hype by their friends in the
press for a big Prime Time Extravaganza
that begins next week
January 6 committee is closing in on
next week's Blockbuster public hearings
the first of the year Congressman Jamie
Raskin has said that these heroes are
going to blow the roof off the capitol
it's official the January 6th public
hearings begin in prime time one week
from tonight can the committee's growing
evidence convince Americans that a coup
was attempted it's finally here and
we're still in suspense Chris
suspense
this is all a show to them and like any
good production they all must play their
parts and what is their role
distraction and demonization
the select committee can paint a clear
narrative a clear frame then that is
going to be critical and starting to
break through some of the noise that we
know they're going to be competing with
on the day-to-day basic news coverage
and what people are up against in their
day-to-day lives
can you believe she admitted that okay
I'm glad we have that on camera
so what are people up against in their
day-to-day lives as she said
two boys who need medical grade formula
for the rest of their lives where they
actually risk permanent brain damage so
this shortage obviously for you Alexa is
it's it's it's life-altering
um you have two weeks of formula left I
understand what are you going to do in
two weeks if there isn't uh Supply if he
doesn't drink his bottles and get his
all of his formula then we're in trouble
the director of all of nutrition who
makes the actual formula has called me
and said it's not even there she can't
get it it's nowhere it's nowhere to be
found so it's not done being made yet
it's heartbreaking from all accounts
that we're seeing and new shipments of
formula are still weeks not days but
weeks away
now as we said for now over a year they
have no hope left to offer
Biden and his team adamantly refuse to
change course because they like the
course we're on
decline is their plan
and they hope to wear you down don't
they so you give up on the promise of
America and accept that failure is
inevitable
but this won't work
it didn't work when Jimmy Carter tried
it and it won't work with Biden and his
clown show staff
America is still the land of
possibilities and we're not going to
surrender to their world view which is
permanent pessimism and self-loathing
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else